during normal times in the economy the
Fed tries to control the amount of
economic activity that's occurring by
targeting the federal funds rate the Fed
the Fed Funds rate and this is the rate
that you always hear talked about on the
news and it's essentially a target rate
that the Fed wants to see banks lending
money lending cash to each other on an
overnight basis and we saw already in
the last video if the Fed does not like
the rate that they're borrowing to each
other and if even announcing the federal
funds rate does not say hey the it
doesn't cause the banks to say hey the
Fed is going to intervene if we don't
bar lend to each other that rate the Fed
can actually intervene it can go out
there perform open market operations and
buy usually Treasury securities out from
the just the general market and what
that does is it increases the amount of
cash that is in circulation which
decreases the demand for cash increases
the supply and it should lower it should
lower the interest rate and the Fed
usually cares about getting that
interest rate within a certain zone
around a certain target and the
Treasuries that the Fed normally buys
are short-term Treasuries and this is
just because this is less risky and
sometimes they'll even make it on a
temporary agreement they'll say look
we'll buy it from you now only if you
agree to purchase it at some future date
at a certain price and that's called a
repurchase agreement I'll do a whole
other video on that but the whole point
of open market operations is to set this
overnight borrowing rate but they deal
they usually deal with the short-term
Treasury debt because it's safer it
exposes the Fed to less interest rate
risk but you could imagine what you
could imagine what happens if the Fed
keeps lowering interest rates in order
to kind of prime the pump in order to
kind of try to stimulate the economy so
it keeps lowering the federal funds rate
from four percent down to three percent
down to two percent maybe going all the
way down eventually to 0% and the whole
time has been doing that by printing
money and buying short-term US
securities and maybe at this point the
yield curve looks like that but maybe
that's not enough maybe the economy is
still tanking maybe people aren't
getting mortgage loans still so now the
Fed can no longer do it
traditional open market operations and
it will no longer be focused on just the
federal funds rate because really it
can't go any lower it already hit zero
short-term overnight borrowing between
banks is already zero but if the Fed
wants to inject more cash it can now buy
different types of securities it can buy
Treasury securities that are so instead
of short-term Treasury securities maybe
it could be longer-term Treasury
securities so maybe stuff that's one
year out five years out ten years out
and the point here would be twofold one
to inject one would be to inject cash
into the system to print cash and put it
out there so it's there for people to
invest and for the banking system to
operate but it might be to explicitly
control the yield curve further out so
that borrowing costs for longer debt
goes down so that the yield curve looks
something like that because if it's
buying longer maturity Treasuries that
will lower the yield or they might even
start to buy things that aren't
Treasuries maybe they'll buy
mortgage-backed securities so it makes
the mortgage market a little bit looser
a little bit more liquid and this
non-traditional type of intervention
where the Fed is no longer concerned
about a target rate because the target
rate is already at zero where the Fed is
not purchasing short-term debt but it
starting to buy longer-term debt for
things further down the yield curve and
maybe things that aren't Treasury
securities to begin with maybe they're
starting to buy corporate debt maybe
they're starting to buy maybe they're
trying to buy mortgage-backed securities
this is called quantitative easing
quantitative easing and there's two
elements to it that make it different
from traditional fed open market
operations they are now no longer
concerned about the Fed fund rate
because it's already at zero the other
thing is is that they're they're they're
buying things maybe further down the
yield curve so they're trying to control
the yield curve itself and they're maybe
buying less traditional securities with
the with the goal of maybe making those
markets a little bit more operational